à l'heure où l'épidémie continue de
progresser en afrique la campagne pour
les élections générales a débuté ce
lundi au burundi le pays qui a pour
l'instant enregistré 15 cas dont un
décès est officiellement l'un des moins
touchés du continent pour le coup
d'envoi de la campagne des milliers de
personnes ont participé aux métiers des
candidats et l'âme medjahed malgré des
mesures prises aux quatre coins du monde
avec notamment des reports des élections
les autorités du bund il semble faire fi
de l'épidémie de kovy 19 l'état
organisera bien le premier tour de la
présidentielle les législatives et les
municipales le 20 mai prochain le
coronavirus qui n'arrêtent pas non plus
les burundais qui se sont rendus par
milliers aux premiers meetings des
candidats ce lundi le cours aulas virus
c'est seulement du qui protégera il n'y
a rien à espérer des hommes
les blancs savait comment se laver les
mains ils sont très intelligents mais on
voit qu'ils ont échoué au burundi le
courant navires us n'arrivera pas
empêcher les gens de se rassembler des
rassemblements géants en pleine pandémie
pour soutenir notamment le leader
historique de l'ex rébellion hutu des
forces nationales de libération
il s'agit d'agathon rwasa candidat du
conseil national pour la liberté
face à lui le candidat du pouvoir en
place le général evariste ndayishimiye
l'héritier du président sortant pierre
nkurunziza qui a renoncé
un nouveau mandat après 15 ans à la tête
du burundi une campagne présidentielle
organisée en grande pompe en présence de
plusieurs diplomates et personnalités
nous allons faire un autre pas vers la
prévention de la santé publique en
prenant soin de la santé de la
population en les protégeant contre des
pandémies et en les soignant quand ils
ont attrapé des maladies sept candidats
dont deux indépendants sont en lice pour
la présidentielle burundaise dans un
climat de répression de l'opposition
l'ombre du 27 avril 2015 plane
d'ailleurs sur le lancement de la
campagne il y a cinq ans se tenait les
manifestations de l'opposition contre
le troisième mandat de pierre nkurunziza
dans un communiqué publié ce lundi human
rights watch dit avoir recensé ces six
derniers mois plusieurs cas de meurtres
disparitions arrestations arbitraires
menaces et harcèlement à l'encontre
d'opposants présumés